that cat so that's gone on here let's
see what all this fuss is about
I'm not marshmallow Yeah right
every single time I got deeper my mouth
it gets worse if you wear the crow mask
yeah why I'm crazy my Chris what is
there's like potatoes running that why
is that
[Music]
that guy's crazy
[Music]
now where is the butter between reality
and dream but as our life I said what is
dreamt or what we dream about down made
their season what would he do view
Conant sleep what do you want a control
over the dream of it does not come but
haunt you and that's a really good
question dad thanks for bringing that
forward daddy I always like audience
participation so you know that way so
what I speak so
okay is that that sorry he's just trying
to get our here
I must up sorry I know he I saw that I'm
trying to walk over here go backwards
nope that's a little annoying keep
getting closer and closer though it's
you think hey not cool bro [ __ ] me sir
ah that's gone out here at the ducky na
the documents
this is just great
HIO scare yeah great
okay and we shall what's gone on here
no I pay the bells I pay the water bill
I make the money that crow is digging
hey anything here nope nope nothing no
no nothing
I pray the bells I get to spend as much
water as I want okay that's how it works
excuse me um because the excess of
duties on all time take care of our
garden as Steven - help me please
somebody help but Lisa could do can't
sage made a good cucina for a child
give me that line you asked when testing
mental ailments sick fat yeah okay so
this marriage really got jacked up
that's any ain't nothing you know she's
a sad ending
nice okay so there's the Lockwood Riley
get that cane here
oh they have a meaning
sorry didn't want to start
Safa that better how do you think I am
that is better good talent here
what the heck here that can I have a
painting like that over there bed any
towels in here I was tough to come in
here for a towel for my wife any towels
in here towels - up there's a towel okay
I got that the wife
yeah I could calm down now step so angry
experience about our relations doing my
employer know him a lot I know it's
conversation we could def lovers oh so
she was having like an affair with edit
does get locked in here
perfect that's gone out here why I
summon across that here hey I should not
be in here
yeah I go yeah got stuck on that for a
second
I'm so clumsy what
well actually saw angry what okay I
guess on this hair thanks for watching
yell thank you